oh
lost contact
the implantation probably wasn't deep
enough
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about raised by wolves season 2 episode
4. it's titled control and things are
continuing to pick up on kepler-22b we
are halfway through this eight episode
season and a lot happened this week to
make the second half feel like it'll be
heading in a different direction just a
ton of developments that happen that
change things up across the different
factions i'll be recapping everything
that happens then i'll circle back to
talk about what it all might mean right
after this quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched the fourth episode of
raised by wolf season 2 yet then this
video won't be for you and with that out
of the way let's get into it the episode
opens with paul and marcus catching up
inside the cave church this is a reunion
that felt inevitable and one that the
trust was definitely counting on one of
the more interesting things that happens
is that paul tells marcus he isn't going
to be able to find the tree because it
hasn't been grown yet he tells him about
the seeds that he believes are inside
the dodecahedron he found and offers to
get him inside the tarantula to recover
them he also reveals that he heard
saul's voice and that it told him what
happened to his real parents in relation
to that marcus asked about sue paul says
he hates her and that it goes beyond
just what they did to get there you know
killing his parents he hates her because
she doesn't believe in soul and he tops
the whole thing off by saying you can't
forgive an atheist in the background we
see campion and virile continue to flirt
if that's what you would call it and
initially they keep it a secret on how
they found out where this place was in
the first place as they're getting ready
to leave paul picks up his bag and we
can see that something's coming out of
it he gets sick from that right away it
turns out that the trust used mouse is a
viral bomb to infect marcus but he turns
out to be immune because of the necro
eyes only paul in one of the mithraics
is infected and they start to get
covered with a mysterious blistering on
their skin marcus takes him outside to
beg soul to heal him and his followers
pieced together that this was all part
of the plan to attack them marcus blames
this all on virile because she brought
them there before and he explodes on
decima telling her to make it right this
is something that's been building up for
him and now he has an actual reason that
he can point to to tell her to get rid
of the android he orders everyone else
to take the tank and tells them he'll
wait for the colonists to come to check
for survivors campion runs off to try to
get mother and decima orders virile to
stop him she gives her a direct order
which she says she can't betray
tamerlane doesn't trust this though so
he follows behind them back at the
colony hunter and tempest are having a
conversation about her giving away her
baby we see the father is still pretty
pleased about his victory and he takes
the fuel blood back to give it to the
ancient android nothing happens right
away but when they lead to go back to
the habitat you see that it absorbs all
that milky goodness
sue goes to visit number seven and while
she's there she finds mother trying to
develop a control chip for it this is
all in an effort to protect her children
but sue points out the obvious thing
that if she's really worried then she
should just kill it she's trying to get
her to admit that it's her child which
she isn't ready to do as campion is
walking back alone he notices something
in the water at the same time virile
catches up with him and when she tries
to stop him she's attacked by one of
those creatures from season one that
seems to have adapted to life under the
acid water it grabs a hold of her and
campion's able to kill it varila is
surprised that he would kill an organic
being to save a synthetic and she asked
him why he would do that we also see
that he finds a leech or something
similar and then tamerlane arrives and
shoots at them champion runs away but he
falls and timberlane's able to catch up
where he has his gun pulled on him until
a glowing light appears behind them in
the forest this turns out to be enough
of a distraction for champion to get
away he runs back and tells mother what
happened and she thinks that he might
have been drugged because he explains
that soul showed himself to him
tamerlane goes back to the group and
tells decima that virile let champion go
this is enough for her to make the
decision to kill her android she cuts up
her face with the scalpel that mother
made from the melted soul pendants from
the children and virile tries to talk
her out of it she brings up the fact
that she broke her neck before and when
she can't convince her she eventually
runs away and jumps off a nearby ledge
to what appears to be her death we see
that decima drops the scalpel when she
sees the android body laying there
motionless below mother arrives to find
marcus standing over paul's body which
is nearly covered with the infection at
this point he tells her that the trust
did this to paul so he won't give him
back they end up fighting after he
reminds her that soul once asked him to
spare her life and that he isn't getting
any such instructions now he gets the
upper hand until campion uses his
slingshot to intervene at that point
mother looks at him and realizes that
his newfound power is coming from her
eyes she's able to pull them from his
stomach up through his mouth and then
she puts them back in and flies the paul
cocoon back to the tarantula cleaver and
his men are in a defensive position and
they see her arrive when he asks the
trust for instructions because it
doesn't know she has her eyes back it
tells him to shoot to destroy her that
prompts her to go full necromancer and
eventually the trust decides that
surrender is the only option she brings
paul in and leaves him with sue and goes
to ask the trust for the antidote it
maintains that there isn't one and
defends the decisions it made the loss
of three children was preferable to the
mass casualties they would have endured
if they had responded with a traditional
attack was this the right decision
obviously it didn't work out but i
suppose it is at least a decision you
can understand it making in these
circumstances the real problem is that
it is in direct conflict with mother's
directive to protect her children and
now that she has her eyes back there
isn't much the atheist or the trust can
do to go against her they would have to
sacrifice a large percentage of their
population to try to stop her after she
refuses to give up her eyes mother does
try to come to an agreement where in
exchange for the trust's help in finding
a cure for paul she'll allow it to
continue functioning it points out that
it can't change what it is all members
of the collective must be treated
equally the algorithm that drives it is
fixed and it can't make special
considerations mother says that she
doesn't want control but is driven by
the fact that she has to keep her
children safe as she's shutting it down
the trust makes what might turn out to
be an important point serving her
children and serving humanity are not
necessarily the same thing it gets cut
off while it's saying it requires
sacrifice shared purpose and ability to
and mother finishes saying seeing beyond
the limits of your own existence this is
something she said about her creator
can't be in sturgis in season 1 while
talking to tempest about being pregnant
so it might be something to remember you
do see the trust powered down but at
this point it's hard for me to imagine
that this is the last we'll hear from it
cleaver breaks down crying when he sees
what happened and the colony starts to
fall apart when they realize they're no
longer under the ai's control mother
makes a speech asking people not to
leave saying she only wants to protect
them she doesn't want power she wants to
cultivate the power that's already
within them and she promises to pass the
baton to a reliable human leader once
that person is identified it doesn't
appear that many of the colonists are
interested in being led by another
synthetic leader at this point though
marcus comes back to reunite with his
followers and you can see that the veins
on his face have disappeared he tells
them that the necromancer got her eyes
back and was able to take paul back to
the collective but he leaves out the
part about how her eyes were inside his
stomach he says that he expects her to
hunt them down and thinks their best
plan is to retreat inland he notices
that barilla's missing and learns from
decima that she made it right he tends
to her wound and tells her she did the
right thing but she notices that the
veins are gone and says that he feels
different you see that sue's trying to
figure out what paul is evolving into
and father returned to his shed which
looks kind of destroyed the table where
the ancient android is is kind of melted
and laying on the ground with a giant
hole in it and he isn't really sure if
this is from the colonist or what
happened here when he notices there's a
hole in the roof he assumes that mother
must have come and taken his project
away then he notices a light and hears a
sound outside and when he goes to look
he sees the android floating above the
ground glowing just like what campion
saw you see something happens with his
eyes that isn't really explained and the
episode ends there
so yeah a lot of turns in this one
marcus losing the eyes feels like it's
going to undermine everything he was
building up as the chosen prophet of
soul and mother getting them back makes
her the most dangerous being on the
planet except whatever father is
bringing back to life appears to have a
lot of the same kind of powers going on
even down to having that thing that he
couldn't remove that was covering her
eyes it seems like a safe bet that she's
something like a proto-necromancer at
the very least and i'm not sure what
we're supposed to make out of what was
going on with father's eyes at the end
there and speaking of eyes i wonder if
it'll turn out to be important that
paul's eyes looked like they were
turning reptilian or whatever was going
on there by the time that he's on sue's
table he appears to be completely
encased to where she wouldn't be able to
notice the difference but they did make
a point to show us that that change
happened i was absolutely surprised that
they built the trust up to just have
mothers shut it down halfway through the
season based on what their individual
directives are all the decisions they
made made sense but it still felt
somewhat anticlimactic i guess it could
be there to show how mother is able to
evolve beyond what she was programmed to
do in a way that the trust wasn't but
generally speaking so far we haven't
seen her act that differently from it
she killed a lot of people in order to
protect her children and as the trust
points out that isn't really compatible
with serving humanity or even giving
them a chance to repopulate this planet
i do wonder if the implication is that
the ancient alien saved champion on
purpose or was it just a coincidence
that she was there at that moment for
all you can tell they might have just
been near the shed when she got loose
but her appearance definitely got him
out of a tough situation some brutal
stuff happened in this episode campion
really came out swinging against the
acid water creature when he wanted to
protect virile and also her getting
chopped up by decima was pretty intense
and i did like the android reactions in
an effort of self-preservation her
response was measured almost cycling
through options trying to find the right
thing to say that might get her out of
the situation while decima is just
freaking out and hacking away at her
face there were also some genuinely
funny moments father saying he hoped
hunter and tempest's ears weren't
damaged by the cheers his victory
elicited and mother ripping the game out
of the table while talking to vida plus
the scenes of her working on the control
chip made me laugh as well it seems like
sue knows that number seven is her child
so it's interesting to see how she won't
admit it and where they're going with
that plus everything else i mean there's
a lot of mysteries it's par for the
course for this show and based on the
teaser for the next episode it looks
like things are gonna continue to
escalate so i think this is a good place
to leave this video and you guys can
tell me in the comments what you think
is going on what you expect to happen in
the second half of the season and what
father father's gonna find when he wakes
up after being knocked out from this
vision of this floating android that he
brought back from the dead please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon